the best YouTubers in the world starting
with Mr Beast Down spend more time and
more money on their thumbnail than you
could ever imagine attention is the
number one asset Dustin and I were
talking about on our trip this week do
we need the hook from the thumbnail to
be delivered on in the first two or
three or 4 seconds we really believe we
do if my hook says 30 to 40 year olds
you should be thinking about LinkedIn
and if my opening line is like before we
get into that in two seconds you may
lose that audience one thing that
continues to work for me is taking
headlines that are happening in pop
culture business and doing a green
screen and talking over it that model
continues to work a great strength of
mind that I would encourage people to
consider is constantly trying new
formats if you have the same exact
format you're doing that 50 100 times
and you're not getting really the
results you want after a 100 times
you've got to change your format maybe
you bring on a guest maybe you go to
written word and picture look I believe
in 40 to 50 core things and then I layer
what's happening in the world at the
time and new in different formats and
platforms